I have come up with the definitive tier
list ranking for public speaking skills.
And in this video, I'm going to start
with the least important, the F
category, and we're going to work our
way up to S, super superior, whatever
the S stands for,
the most important public speaking
skills. You're going to want to watch
this video all the way through to the
end because there are a few surprises.
Some of my picks are going to get push
back in the comments. I already know it.
And the first one I have for C is So,
here we go. Let's jump in. Starting with
the F category. One of the worst things
you can do as a public speaker is start
your speech with a dictionary
definition. Ladies and gentlemen,
Webster's dictionary defines love as
Uh, this is a terrible way to start a
speech. It's so cliché. Some people have
done this with wedding speeches. Do not
start with a dictionary definition. This
is not strong. There are much better
ways to start your speech. The next
public speaking habit that falls into
the F tier, the lowest tier, something
you want to avoid, is apologizing before
you start speaking.
Hey everyone. I'm I'm sorry. I'm I'm not
a public speaker. I'm actually really
nervous right now. So, uh, bear with me.
This is not the way to start your
speech. It takes away credibility. It
shows a lack of confidence. Instead, you
want to jump in. You want to practice,
and you want to show authority with that
speech because if you have been asked to
give a presentation,
you've been asked for a reason. So, I'd
love you to have confidence, but do not
apologize. Apologizing before you start
speaking is an F tier ranking. The final
F-tier ranking when it comes to public
speaking skills, and the two previous
were dictionary definitions of words and
apologizing before you speak, is reading
off of your slides. And this is probably
the most common of the F-tier category.
It's when speakers have slideshow
presentations, and then they feel the
need to turn their back to the audience
and read all of the words that are on
the slide.
That is incredibly boring. It shows that
you're not confident in your material,
that you don't have strong communication
skills, and it's almost like you're
learning along with the audience the
information you're supposed to be
presenting.
If you do have slides, limit the amount
of text. I'm talking three to five words
max. Have big images, and it should
simply supplement what you're talking
about. But the idea of reading
information off of a slide is the lowest
tier of public speaking skill. It is
something you should absolutely avoid.
Time to talk about the D category for my
tier list of public speaking skills. And
the first one I have for the D category
might get some pushback. There may be
some people in the comments who don't
like this one, but I'm sticking to it.
And that is starting your speech with
thank you.
If you stand up on stage and the first
words out of your mouth is "Thank you
for this opportunity. I'd like to thank
everyone for for being here, for taking
time out of your day." This is a weak
speech opening. Instead, there are many
things you can do. You can jump right
into a story. You can ask a
thought-provoking question. But starting
with thank yous is something that's
incredibly common, and it's a pattern
that audiences are used to, but it
doesn't mean it's a strong way to open
your speech. And I'm not saying you
shouldn't thank the audience at some
point, but don't thank them as the first
words that you say. The next public
speaking practice that I would rank as a
D for the tier list is standing behind a
lectern. Now, many stages when you give
a presentation, they will have a lectern
on the stage and a lot of people like to
grip the sides of the lectern and stand
right behind it.
I don't want you to do that. I actually
want you to step away from the lectern
completely and especially if you have
the ability to have a handheld or a lav
mic,
walk around that stage because when
we're trapped behind a lectern, it
limits our ability to have body
language, vocal variety, we often get in
the habit of reading notes, and it is a
weak public speaking skill. So, those
who stand behind a lectern, I would rank
them on the D list for the tier list of
public speaking. I am ranking 24 public
speaking skills and my final skill for
the D tier,
we're starting with the worst, we're
getting to the best, is the idea of
memorizing a speech word for word.
The problem with this is it doesn't give
any ability for the speaker to adapt. If
you've written out a speech that's let's
say it's 700 words on a word document
and you've memorized every single word
and even if you've practiced a lot,
there are so many things that could
happen on the day of the speech that
cause you to forget whatever it was that
you had practiced or memorized. Maybe
it's the nerves are getting to you.
Maybe there's a distraction or a loud
noise and all of a sudden you're
derailed.
What's much better is to build your
speech into chunks
and be adaptable within those chunks so
that the practice versions are similar,
but they can be a little bit different
every time because you haven't written
down every single word exactly verbatim.
The best way to practice your speech is
in chunks. Don't get in the habit of
trying to memorize your speech
perfectly. I'm in the midst of ranking
24 public speaking skills starting with
the lowest category of F and moving our
way up to S. We've already tackled F.
We've already tackled D. Now we're on to
the C category and C might as well stand
for controversial cuz some of my picks
are going to get pushback in the
comments. I already know it. And the
first one I have for C is dress and
appearance.
I realize that you have to wear a
certain thing to a wedding, whether it
be a dress or whether it be a suit, and
I understand that there are formal
business functions where you should
probably be dressed up in professional
attire.
But I am saying that this is C in terms
of how important it is. And what I'm
basing this on is some of the best
presenters I have seen are not those who
go over the top with suits and ties and
dresses, but are actually quite casual.
And maybe just like I'm have for this
video, they have a hat or a sweater that
they're wearing. Yet, they are confident
in the material that they are speaking
about and they are subject matter matter
experts.
>> [snorts]
>> Therefore, I am ranking dress and
appearance as a C. And I still think
it's important for you to understand
what the event is and try to abide by
the overall dress code, but don't get
too hung up on your outfit specifically,
cuz I think it's much more important
having confidence and a strong stage
presence. The next public speaking skill
that I'm going to put into the C tier
category is vocabulary.
And some speakers have an incredible
vocabulary where they will use words
that
evoke imagery and cause the audience to
feel immersed in what they are talking
about,
but I've also seen speakers who are very
simple with their vocabulary, but are
still able to make an impact on the
audience. So, this is a nice to have,
but I don't think it's one of the most
essential things. And when I'm going
through 24 public speaking skills and
I'm having to disperse these and rank
them, I think vocabulary is a little on
the less important side. But let me know
in the comments. Perhaps I'm way off on
this, but I'm giving vocabulary a C
ranking. My final C category tier list
ranking for public speaking skills is
one that is probably the most
controversial of this entire list, and
I'm expecting pushback,
but it's filler words.
Filler words are um they are uh
those um
uh
words and sounds that creep in between
sentences that we would probably be
better suited to simply replace with
silence, because these words or sounds
don't add any value to what we're
saying.
But,
some of my favorite public speakers
use a lot of filler words. And this is
what I'm basing this ranking on is while
I think the most polished
great presenters
have done a good job of removing these
words and it does make you sound a bit
more professional the fewer filler words
you use.
I've seen too many great speakers who
have amazing content
are able to share valuable information
but they do get hung up on the filler
words. Therefore, it goes to show me
that this isn't a requirement. It's a
C-level tier. But I know there's going
to be people who disagree with me on
this. I personally have worked very hard
to eliminate as many filler words from
my speeches as possible.
What do you think? Is this C tier or
should I have bumped it up higher? We
are moving up the list of 24 public
speaking skills that are ranked from F
all the way up to S tier and we are now
at the B category and the first one I
have for B is transitions.
And I love that this is part of the B
category cuz it's probably not something
that a lot of people think about.
But great speakers and especially great
MCs have the seamless ability to make
various things transition.
So for MCs, it may be thanking a speaker
and then transitioning to the next
speaker.
For somebody who is giving a full-out
keynote speech, it might be the ability
to transition seamlessly between various
ideas which makes the speech feel
cohesive.
Transitions in my mind is something that
not many people talk about, but it is
something that's pretty high up there on
the scale. So I'm giving it a B tier
ranking. The next category I have given
a B ranking in terms of public speaking
skills is energy and enthusiasm.
This is something that is very
important. It's not quite an A, it's not
quite an S,
but your audience will feed off of your
own energy.
And the reason I gave this a B versus an
A or an S is that I have seen some great
speakers
who are a little bit lower energy.
But they're simply subject matter
experts.
And on the flip side, I've seen some
poor speakers who come up with a crazy
amount of energy,
but it clearly flo- falls flat after the
audience realizes maybe they're not as
much of an expert in the subject matter
as they originally portrayed.
But this is still important, and you can
practice this. Practice bringing the
energy because it's important to capture
and recapture the audience's attention.
And if you come out flat and monotone,
and you don't have that enthusiasm,
it's less likely you're going to hold
the attention of your audience. Moving
up the scale of the 24 public speaking
skills and their rankings on my tier
list, I'm giving a B in terms of
importance to audience awareness.
This is something that is quite
important, but it's maybe not quite at
that A or that S level.
And what I love about audience awareness
is this showcases adaptability of
speakers.
So, the best speakers are the ones who
are in the moment giving their
presentation, and then something
happens. Somebody spills a glass of
water. Somebody lets out a laugh that
gets the attention of everyone cuz it's
a crazy sounding laugh.
A glass drops and breaks. There's all
sorts of different things that could
happen, and the best speakers will
analyze that in the moment, in the
middle of their speech, and then make a
decision.
Do they address it? Do they comment on
it? Do they make a joke? Or do they
continue and they power through and they
ignore it?
And being able to make that decision in
real time is something that elite
speakers can do.
However, some people don't have that
ability but still have great information
and have practiced their speech so much
that the information is still good.
Therefore, audience awareness for me is
a B. The next public speaking skill I
have ranked as a B in terms of
importance is the closing.
How the speech wraps up. And one of my
favorite ways that speeches can wrap up
is something called full circle. And
[snorts] the idea here is that the very
first thing you mention in your speech
is also the last thing you mention.
And there's something nice about this
that makes it feel as though it's all
come together.
So the closing of your speech is
incredibly important. Why didn't I rank
this as an A or an S level?
I've still seen many great speakers give
powerful presentations and then end sort
of abruptly with well, thanks so much.
Hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference
or something like that. And so I think
that these people could improve but it
didn't take away that much from the
overall presentation. So the closing, I
was close to ranking this an A but in
the end I gave it the B ranking. Do you
agree with me? Do you disagree? Let me
know. The final B tier public speaking
skill as part of this ranking that I'm
doing from F to S in terms of the worst
to the best public speaking skills is
pacing.
Pacing is great because it can immerse
the audience in what you're talking
about. And if you were really stressed
before giving a presentation and all of
a sudden you found out that your
presentation was going to have to be a
little bit longer because the agenda was
was running quick and they needed to
fill time and so the event organizer
asked you to lengthen your speech and
you were stressed out and you had so
much anxiety and then you stepped up on
the stage
and everyone was looking at you.
And for a moment you froze.
But then you remembered what your first
line was
and you jumped in and you re-engaged the
audience.
Pacing can immerse your audience in the
story. It can make them feel like they
are there with you experiencing whatever
it is you're talking about
but it is an elite skill and I don't
know that it is an A or an S ranking.
It's not that essential. There's other
skills as we'll talk about that are a
little bit higher on the importance but
pacing still is a very valuable skill.
I'm giving it a B ranking. All right,
we're moving up to the A category of
public speaking skills, what I consider
to be the most important public speaking
skills
and previously
I've put some pretty well-known public
speaking skills into lower categories.
For example, I gave filler words, the
uhs, ums, uhs, a C in terms of
importance.
I gave audience awareness, which seems
pretty important, a B.
And the reason for this is that this A
category
I'm looking for the elite, the really
important skills. And the first thing I
have in the A category is preparation.
Practice. There is no replacement for
practicing your speech and I think that
most speakers need to practice multiple
times before they give their
presentation. And we've romanticized
this idea of being able to wing it when
it comes to a speech and do it
completely off the top of our head,
but that's not going to result in the
best speech possible. And even the
people who are able to wing it, I think
would be better served with more
practice. But by going through the reps
and practicing your speech often, that's
going to give you an incredible amount
of irreplaceable confidence when you
actually go to deliver your speech. The
next public speaking skill that I have
given an A tier list ranking
is pausing.
Pausing is the underdog of public
speaking skills.
I don't think people realize how
important the ability to pause really is
when speaking,
but what it does is it allows your
audience to think.
It allows an idea or a powerful thought
to really set in.
And for you, the speaker,
if you have the ability to pause,
especially after you say something
profound or significant,
you come across
as an incredible authority on that
subject matter.
Your audience is going to respect you.
You're going to look like an absolute
professional on whatever it is that
you're talking about.
So by mastering this ability to pause
with confidence,
that's going to allow you to be a very
strong speaker. This is why I'm giving
pausing an A ranking. The next public
speaking skill that I am choosing to
give an A ranking on my tier list in
terms of importance
is the hook.
How do you hook the audience's attention
within the first few seconds?
And here's [snorts] a tip.
There are three main ways, three easy to
remember ways to do this.
The first is to jump right into a story.
Forget the formalities, forget
introducing yourself.
The first words out of your mouth on
stage are the first words of your story.
And you immerse the audience in the
story right away. That is probably the
most powerful way to hook an audience's
attention.
Another way is to ask a really
thought-provoking question,
especially if it causes a little bit of
friction.
Because now the audience is curious.
Where's this going to go?
I'm super interested.
The final idea is to give a really
powerful stat that maybe most people in
the room have no idea about.
These are three ways to hook your
audience's attention, but the reality is
audiences will judge whether or not they
find a speaker interesting within the
first few seconds. And so ensuring that
you hook their attention,
that gives you a much better chance that
they will pay attention for the full
speech. The next public speaking skill
that I am giving an A-level ranking
is eye contact.
Eye contact creates accountability. And
so when you're giving a presentation,
I want you to do your best to scan the
room. And if you're presenting to a
large room, it's hard to make eye
contact with every single person, but
periodically moving throughout the room
and making eye contacts with areas
of the room,
it creates that feeling that you're
speaking to everyone.
And it will cause the audience to be
less distracted because there's a lot of
things vying for our attention when
we're listening to a speech, namely our
phones. But if the speaker is doing a
good job of scanning the room,
the audience is less likely to want to
look away. They'll they'll want to have
their focus on you, the speaker. And an
important thing to remember, if you're
giving a virtual or a Zoom presentation,
this is eye contact. Looking directly at
the camera or the webcam. A mistake some
people make is looking down at the faces
that are on the screen who you are
talking to, but that's not eye contact.
This is eye contact. So, this is a skill
that I am ranking in the A category. A
few years ago, I created a Udemy course
called The Five Essentials of Public
Speaking,
but I debated having a sixth skill that
I added in,
and that is this one that I am giving an
A-level ranking, and that is humor.
Humor is such a powerful tool to use as
a public speaker because it relaxes your
audience.
As soon as people in your audience are
laughing,
they're going to think, "Okay, this
speaker knows what he or she is doing. I
can relax cuz this is going to be
enjoyable."
And for you, the speaker, if you hear
the audience laughing, that is your
instant sign that they are enjoying
themselves, which creates a level of
relaxation for yourself, because you
know, "Hey, this is going pretty well."
And so, using humor is very powerful.
The reason it's not an S-tier level is
because there are still great speakers
who don't inject much humor in their
talks, but they are such experts in what
they are talking about that the
information is still compelling. So,
it's not an essential essential, but
it's pretty close. My final A-tier level
public speaking skill in this chart of
24 speaking skills and how I've ranked
all of them is speech structure.
Speech structure is very important
because this is going to allow the
audience to follow along and hopefully
get as much value from your presentation
as possible.
And there are those people who can just
stand in front of a room and sort of
wing it, and talk about whatever comes
to mind,
but if it's disjointed, if it's not
clear what the audience should be taking
away from that presentation,
it's sort of pointless.
Because your whole goal as a speaker
should be to speak to the audience, to
deliver them with value with value, and
for them to have tangible takeaways.
But if you're just sort of up there for
the point of being up there and talking
without any sort of purpose or
structure,
it's sort of losing the point. So,
building a speech structure is very
important. I've done several videos on
five-point speech structures, which I
think are the easiest to remember and
allow you to detach from using notes,
which allows you to do so many of these
other skills that we're talking about.
But speech structure is an A-level
public speaking skill. All right, we've
made it to the S category, the highest
category that we have, super, superior,
whatever the S is supposed to stand for
on this tier list.
And the first thing is authenticity.
If you are trying to be somebody who you
are not from the stage, if you're trying
to crack canned jokes from the internet,
and you're somebody who
that totally goes against your style and
your personality,
the audience will be able to tell.
This isn't to say that you can't
improve, or if you're somebody who has
struggled with public speaking in the
past, that is the person you are, and
you're never destined to give a good
speech.
That's not what I'm saying. Like
anything, we can work on these skills,
we can practice, we can enhance.
But when it comes down to the core of
your message, and what you're speaking
about, I believe authenticity is an
S-level
category. It is so important. And so,
always fall back on that. Whatever
speech you're building,
keep it to the core of who you are,
and that will guide you well. The next
public speaking skill that made it to
the highest category, the S-level,
vocal variety.
The ability to get loud with your voice
or soften it
when you really want a point to sink in.
Or if you're telling something
emotional,
what we do with our voice is such a
powerful tool, and I would suggest it's
underrated. But, there's some research
that suggests 38% of how a message is
communicated is based on the vocal tone
and variety.
And if we want the audience to
continually be paying attention,
we want to use our voice as an
instrument that does that, that adds to
the story, that not only gets louder or
softer,
but can change in the pacing
and bring everything together.
Earlier on the on the tier list, I
ranked a couple things specifically like
pausing and pacing,
and those were pretty high ranked on
their own. But, for me, vocal variety
encapsulates all of this, and I think it
is something that is worthy of the
S-tier and something all of us as
presenters continually can be working
on. 55% of how a message is communicated
is done so not through the words that we
speak, not through how our voice sounds,
but through body language.
What are we doing with our bodies? What
are we doing with our hands? What are we
doing with our facial expressions? How
are we moving on the stage or not moving
on the stage? This is so incredibly
important for how a message is
communicated, and this is why I'm
putting body language in the S tier, the
highest category on this public speaking
tier list, because it is such an
essential piece of allowing us to
connect with the audience.
Which goes back to an earlier tip I
gave, if there's a lectern
on stage, I don't want you to get
trapped behind that lectern, gripping
the sides and reading notes.
That is one of the weakest ways to
deliver a presentation.
I want you to move away from the lectern
and use your body. Use hand gestures,
facial expressions to add and reinforce
whatever it is that you're talking
about. Body language is perhaps the most
important public speaking skill, but
certainly amongst the top. All right,
are you ready for it? The final S
category public speaking skill on my
definitive tier list of ranking 24
public speaking skills. For those of you
who have followed along this far with
all of these different skills, thank
you. There were some surprises along the
way. For example, I only gave filler
words a C ranking. I only gave audience
awareness a B ranking.
But this one is something that deserves
S, and that is the ability to tell a
great story.
Stories are remembered 22 times more
than facts alone,
and they're essential. If we want the
audience to walk away with tangible
takeaways from our presentation, we are
best served to inject stories within
that presentation, cuz it will help the
audience to remember
whatever it is that we're talking about,
cuz they'll think of the stories that we
told.
And here's the other great part about
stories.
They don't require notes.
If you were telling stories from lived
experiences you have had, you don't need
to write that down word for word and try
to memorize it.
That lives up here.
So now when you're building your speech,
it becomes less about writing something
out verbatim and more about putting a
puzzle with ideas and stories together
and making this work in a cohesive way.
Storytelling is my final public speaking
skill that I am adding to the S tier
because stories are that important. I
hope this list, the definitive top-tier
list of rankings F D C B A S has been
beneficial to you. Which ones did I get
wrong? Let me know in the comments. I
know there's going to be pushback on
some of these. Let me know how you would
have recategorized these. Which rankings
should have been moved to which
categories? I can't wait to see how some
of you have broken these down in the
comments below. If you've not already
subscribed to my channel, please do so.
And if you want to level up on any of
these 24 public speaking skills, check
out my Stand Store in the links below or
send me a comment. Let's get working
together. I'd love to help you level up
and become more professional when it
comes to your own public speaking
skills. And check out the video that
YouTube is recommending for you. Thanks
for watching this one.